what is the the big thing that you wish  everyone knew about money before they  started making it oh man well it goes  back to I guess just the basics because  most of us myself included are never  taught a thing a thing about money we're  told go to school get a degree  get a job and now you figure it out  right and then what happens for the  majority of people is you end up broke  you end up struggling financially and  you you can never figure out why so the  first thing is what is it that you want  to achieve in your life financially and  then you have to go out and figure it  out yourself because unfortunately  school will never teach you the stuff